we are going to begin with war clouds in
eastern europe signs of a conflict
between russia and ukraine and it could
erupt soon with more than a hundred
thousand russian troops amassed near the
ukrainian border the u.s state
department has ordered families of
american diplomats to get out of the
country now they've advised all private
u.s citizens to do the same along with
non-essential american embassy personnel
now those russian forces are deployed on
three sides of ukraine as you can see in
the map here but moscow is denying a
british government report that it wants
to install a puppet government in the
country holly williams is inside ukraine
for us this morning holly good morning
good morning well the families of
american diplomats here at the u.s and
embassy in kiev are leaving ukraine but
some ukrainians have told us that they
have nowhere to run and can only hope
for peace with the threat of russian
attack hanging over them
a crossing point on ukraine's northern
border with russia
on the other side of this frontier
are around a hundred thousand russian
troops
and to the west russian fighter jets and
missile systems are moving into place in
belarus for what russia says are
military exercises
it's been 30 years since the cold war
ended inspiring hopes of a safer and
more stable world but now a u.s ally
here in europe is living in fear of a
russian invasion
nino balaya lives in the nearest village
potentially in the firing line if
there's any kind of russian incursion
she showed us her cellar where she
stores food for the winter she has
another purpose in mind if the russians
show up you can take shelter down here
if the russians invade
most ukrainians are far from wealthy now
their freedom and their young democracy
are threatened by their colossal
neighbour
and what some say is president vladimir
putin's ambition to create a new russian
empire
russia claims it has no plans to invade
and blames the u.s and its allies for
ratcheting up tensions by arming ukraine
in truth this country is already
fighting russian-backed separatists
and the us is supporting it with
training and weapons
200 million dollars of emergency
military assistance from america has
already started arriving what they do is
they they twist uh reality they are
always
uh denying you know what is what is
quite obvious you know in terms of the
the the form of aggression that they're
undertaking general h.r mcmaster is a
former national security adviser and
says president putin only understands
deterrence
what lessons should the u.s have learned
by this point about how to negotiate
with russia how to negotiate with putin
power holly right it's power i think i
think putin understands this putin will
take whatever he can get
another shipment of american military
equipment and munitions is expected to
arrive here in kiev tomorrow morning
meanwhile nato has just announced that
it is sending troops fighter jets and a
warship to bolster defenses in eastern
europe gail
all right holly williams reporting from
ukraine thank you very much holly